JOANNA SMITH: This
week, we're talking
about strategy guides,
cheat codes, and graphics
for Google Cloud Platform.
I'm Joanna, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Moving to the
cloud is important,
but so is thinking
critically about which
parts of your business it
actually makes sense to move.
To guide you, we've got
a post for all the CIOs
is currently wrestling
with this question.
In it, will bust your myths
about migrating and detail
how it's possible to decouple
dependencies for more agility,
without adding
unnecessary complexity.
Like that sentence.
Virtual display devices
for Chrome enterprise
are now generally
available, meaning
you can add a virtual
display device to any VM
on Google Cloud.
This gives your VM video
graphics array capabilities
without having to use GPUs,
which can be powerful, but also
expensive.
Get the full scoop
on the Cloud Blog.
One of the greatest
challenges customers
face when onboarding
in the cloud
is how to control and protect
their assets while letting
their users deploy
resources securely.
So we created this
series of posts
to show you how to write your
security policies as code, once
and for all, and to
apply them both before
and after you deploy resources
in your GCP environment.
The first post is about using
Forseti Config Validator.
It's no secret that Google
Cloud offers a lot of products.
To help you understand
the differences,
Greg Wilson has a cheat sheet.
It's simple.
All of the approximately
222 products we offer
explained in four words or less.
Let it be your light when
looking to the cloud.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us,
and we'll see you in the cloud.